anytime you do any sort of physical
scene with Leonardo DiCaprio he doesn't
understand that it's acting and he beats
the living crap out of you for six
months as you can see in the lewd fight
or any other scene I get punched in the
face I got punched in the face for real
feels like I gotta get him back and
since I can't physically beat him up
back because he's bigger than me I had
to use my brain to to beat him up there
was a scene which is my favorite scene
between us it is my favorite team I've
ever shot in a movie actually and in the
in the sushi scene the line was written
as I was supposed to say do you want
that last piece of yellow tape and I was
supposed to say yes and then eat it and
the first hey he goes take that last
piece of yellowtail and I go that's all
it's all yours and then so he had to eat
it so he had to match that tank for the
rest of the night
and then by the end of the night he was
on the floor throwing up into a
waistband and everyone was like Leo hey
are you okay and the only two people
who are laughing hysterically were
myself and Martin Scorsese
and the better moments of the whole
shoot I guess you're brave it's better
than your muscles